la diabetes tipo 2 es una afección en la
cual el nivel de azúcar en la sangre es
muy elevado después de que usted come
alimentos que contienen carbohidratos
los productos químicos en el intestino
delgado los descomponen en moléculas de
azúcar simple llamadas glucosa luego las
células que recubren el intestino
delgado absorben la glucosa
la cual pasa al torrente sanguíneo
cuando la sangre llega al páncreas las
células beta del páncreas detectan el
incremento de los niveles de glucosa las
células beta liberan insulina en el
torrente sanguíneo para reducir los
niveles de glucosa
a medida que la sangre circula a través
del cuerpo la insulina y la glucosa
salen del torrente sanguíneo hacia los
tejidos para alcanzar las células del
cuerpo la mayoría de las células del
cuerpo tienen ciertos receptores en su
superficie que se unen a la insulina
circulante
la insulina actúa como la llave de una
cerradura para abrir la célula de tal
manera que la glucosa circulante pueda
ingresar a dicha célula
ahora las células pueden aprovechar la
glucosa y producir la energía que
necesitan para funcionar correctamente
si usted sufre de diabetes tipo 2
entonces el páncreas no produce
suficiente insulina las células del
cuerpo resisten sus efectos y ocurren
ambas cosas
si tiene resistencia a la insulina su
insulina no puede abrir las células para
dejar ingresar a la glucosa porque las
cerraduras llamados receptores son
anormales o están ausentes como
consecuencia la glucosa queda sin acceso
a las células por consiguiente la
glucosa se acumula en el torrente
sanguíneo durante una afección llamada
hiperglucemia
para compensar la hiperglucemia el
páncreas produce más y más insulina
las células beta trabajan en exceso e
intentan mantener la demanda pero poco a
poco van perdiendo la capacidad de
producir insulina suficiente
debido a la hiperglucemia y la falta de
insulina podría experimentar los
siguientes síntomas clásicos de la
diabetes apetito y sed excesivos
aumento en el volumen de orina y pérdida
de peso inexplicable
los síntomas de la diabetes tipo 2 que
pueden presentarse con el paso del
tiempo son cansancio infecciones
recurrentes cambios en la visión picazón
y sensación de hormigueo o cosquilleo en
la piel
y las complicaciones que ponen en riesgo
la vida producidas por la diabetes tipo
2 incluyen cetoacidosis diabética
síndrome hiperglucemia hiperosmolar no
se tóxico e hipoglucemia
si no recibe tratamiento para la
hiperglucemia puede ocurrir una
situación sis diabética
debido a que ya no tiene insulina
suficiente circulando en la sangre las
células no reciben la glucosa que
necesitan para producir energía como
consecuencia la sangre recurrió a las
grasas y proteínas como fuente de
energía alternativa
durante el proceso de descomposición de
grasas ciertos subproductos conocidos
como cuerpos cetónicos se acumulan en la
sangre dando lugar a una afección
llamada cetosis si los cuerpos de
tóxicos se acumulan a niveles
peligrosamente altos en el torrente
sanguíneo puede desarrollarse tu
acidosis diabética o cda que puede
derivar en un coma y la muerte
otra complicación que se deriva de no
tratar la hiperglucemia se llama
síndrome hiperglucemia hiperosmolar no
se tóxico o shh nc a medida que la
deficiencia de insulina continúa su
nivel de glucosa en sangre aumenta como
respuesta los riñones filtran el exceso
de glucosa fuera de la sangre en la
orina junto con grandes cantidades de
agua
a menos que consuma grandes cantidades
de agua los riñones no podrán mantener
la demanda de eliminar la glucosa del
torrente sanguíneo y de diluir la en la
orina en forma suficiente como
consecuencia la sangre estará mucho más
concentrada de lo normal una afección
llamada hiperosmolar y that la hiper
osmolaridad arrastra el agua de los
tejidos corporales al torrente sanguíneo
y ocasiona una grave deshidratación que
puede derivar en síndrome hiperglucemia
hiperosmolar no se tóxico pueden
aparecer síntomas neurológicos como
convulsiones y coma
si ingiere una dosis excesiva de
medicamento para la diabetes puede
experimentar una complicación aguda
llamada hipoglucemia o choque insulínico
el exceso de insulina o medicamento
hiperglucemia oral hace que haya
demasiada glucosa en las células lo cual
deja una cantidad insuficiente en el
torrente sanguíneo
algunos órganos como el cerebro
necesitan un suministro de energía
constante para funcionar en forma
adecuada debido a que la fuente de
energía del cerebro es la glucosa este
es el primer órgano afectado por los
bajos niveles de glucosa
cuando las células del cerebro llamadas
neuronas tienen gran necesidad de
glucosa empiezan a funcionar mal lo que
causa síntomas como nerviosismo
temblores y confusión si el nivel de
glucosa sigue bajando
la actividad eléctrica de las neuronas
disminuye en forma significativa y tiene
como consecuencia convulsiones o coma
diabético
con el tiempo la diabetes tipo 2 crónica
mal controlada puede causar daño
degenerativo en el tejido que tiene como
consecuencia complicaciones a largo
plazo como aterosclerosis ceguera
neuropatía e insuficiencia renal
a fin de evitar las complicaciones de la
diabetes tipo 2 puede tomar medidas para
mantener el nivel de glucosa dentro del
intervalo normal mediante el uso de una
combinación de control de la glucosa en
sangre una dieta sana ejercicio regular
y medicamentos según sea necesario
deberá controlar el nivel de glucosa en
sangre en forma frecuente con un
glucómetro para esto debe pincharse el
dedo con una aguja pequeña llamada
lanceta y colocar una gota de sangre en
la tira del glucómetro considerando su
nivel de azúcar en sangre quizá deba
ajustar sus comidas la actividad física
o la dosis de los medicamentos llevar
una dieta saludable ayudará a disminuir
su nivel de glucosa cuando consuma
abundantes frutas verduras y granos
enteros realice sus comidas y
refrigerios a la misma hora todos los
días
consume una cantidad balanceada de
carbohidratos proteínas y grasas y
minimiza su ingesta de alimentos con
alto contenido de azúcar
la realización de ejercicios en forma
regular incluso solo 30 minutos al día
disminuirá su nivel de glucosa en sangre
disminuirá su resistencia a la insulina
y podría derivar en la pérdida de peso
quizá necesite uno o más medicamentos
para la diabetes para ayudar a disminuir
su glucosa en sangre algunos de estos
medicamentos aumentan la producción de
insulina en el páncreas
otros disminuyen la resistencia a la
insulina en los músculos esqueléticos
algunos tratamientos aumentan la
sensibilidad a la insulina en
determinados tejidos otros promueven una
leve disminución de la absorción de
glucosa en el sistema digestivo
si no es posible controlar la diabetes
tipo 2 mediante dieta ejercicios y
medicamentos orales su médico podría
recetar la insulina y capacitarlo para
aplicarse inyecciones subcutáneas
al tratar y controlar su nivel de
glucosa en sangre puede evitar la
ocurrencia de complicaciones de la
diabetes tipo 2